on va revenir en plateau peut-être pour
retrouver nos nouveaux invités alors
nous avons en ligne jacques benillouche
journaliste indépendant et michel rambo
essayiste et ancien ambassadeur de
france merci à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous alors jacques
benillouche est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire un mot d'abord sur la
situation en israël et à gaza
actuellement est ce qu'il ya un espoir
aujourd'hui de désescalade ou est-ce
qu'il faudra attendre plusieurs jours
voire plusieurs semaines
je pense qu'il faut d'abord avant de
penser à discuter et saigner mauvaise
essayé d'expliquer la situation je vais
prendre en seconde pour vous expliquer
que nous avons fait l'une d'un problème
israelo israélien un problème
international leur le mois de ramadhan
le vendredi de ramadan
la police israélienne a décidé de mettre
des barrages sur le mont du temple
bredele à près de la mosquée el aqsa et
puis elle a été décidée de d'interdire
les marches de ce temple pour les as je
comprends et ça ça a été une erreur
c'est une décision du gouvernement qui a
été condamnée par beaucoup de gens parce
que ça fait 20 ans que le les fêtes se
passe autrement dans la liberté totale
de la part des deux défenses de police
et c'est à ce moment là que on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait des manifestants
qui n'étaient pas contents de cette
décision de police et par la suite on a
le gouvernement a laissé faire en
permettant à des extrémistes d'extrême
droite de pas de participer à ces
manifestations à l'intérieur du mot al
aqsa ou à l'extérieur pour pouvoir
compléter les les troubles vous savez ce
c'est une affaire purement israélienne
qui étaient là et on a on a on n'a pas
le gouvernement je j'avoue que je
condamne
le gouvernement dans cette affaire il
n'aurait pas dû
or il n'y aurait pas du réchauffé la
situation or il habille besoin de la
réchauffer parle parce que le premier
ministre est en difficulté était en
difficulté il y avait un gouvernement
qu'ils étaient prêts à être créé avec la
participation d'un parti arabe
islamistes je dis bien partis arabes
islamistes qui devait arriver au pouvoir
et bien le gouvernement actuel
natanyahou a créé cet incident pour
empêcher la création de ce gouvernement
ça c'est purement israélien or que s'est
il passé pour des raisons qu'on ignore
leur hamas a dit je vais venir protéger
et soutenir les populations arabes en
israël ce n'est pas son travail
ce n'est pas cette responsabilité et
qu'at-il fait pour les soutenir
il a envoyé mille missiles moi j'ai eu 4
4 à lens 4 à weert de chez moi j'en ai
vu tout à l'heure à une heure et une
autre à 1h30 on a reçu des cils au
dessus du toit
donc je pense que le ramasse s'est
comporté dans cette affaire comme un
complice du gouvernement israélien c'est
à dire qu'il a permis aux gouvernements
israéliens d'empêcher la formation d'une
unité
je dirais nationale ou les arabes
devaient être impliqués et devait
participer
alors là donc c'est pour ça que je dis à
l'heure actuelle pourquoi le ramasse
s'est permis de lancer des missiles
mille missiles
le premier jour aujourd'hui on a là
encore mille qui nous tombe sur la tête
et vous croyez que nous allons même si
nous sommes anti du contre le
gouvernement vous croyez que nous allons
attendre tranquillement d'être détruit
par des miliciens islamistes
donc c'est inadmissible il faut savoir
qui a commencé
celui qui a commencé c'est celui qui a
lancé les missiles sur israël
donc messieurs besoin on va écouter
michel raimbault
vous êtes d'accord avec jacques béni
ouch c'est le hamas avec ses tirs de
roquettes qui a commencé les hostilités
ne suis pas très d'accord parce que
l'histoire n'a pas commencé il ya quinze
jours on continue beaucoup plus en tant
que ça et toute façon je crois qu'il ya
une situation qui purent très très
longtemps et une situation qui ne
respecte pas le droit international et
ensuite il ya les palestiniens des
droits
je crois qu'ils sont en situation plutôt
victime plutôt basse poisson d'attaquant
et je crois qu'il faut aussi il faut
abandonner l'idée si on veut trouver une
solution que finalement ce qui se passe
et 1 contre le hamas dans le stadiste
et puis l'état d'israël en fait c'est
tout le peuple palestinien
je pense après sur l'expression
politique c'est la sphère des
palestiniens on a expliqué qu'elle ne
pourrait que enfin bon je crois qu'il
faut mettre fin à ce mythe c'est tout
autre palestinien qui est considéré
comme un acteur de seconde zone qui
était occupée et ensuite qui n'est pas
traitée lui dans le droit international
et suivant la justice on ne voit bien à
lui et je vais vous dire par les faits
si vous aussi vous permettez il faut
savoir que dans tous ces événements la
population de cisjordanie n'a pas bougé
il n'y a eu aucune manifestation de la
part des palestiniens de cisjordanie
pourquoi parce qu'ils savent quel est
leur intérêt ils savent qu'ils gagnent
leur vie en venant traversé tous les
mois cent cinquante mille palestiniens
tiens travaillant dix vies or comment
expliquez vous monsieur que les
palestiniens de cisjordanie qui sont eux
les vrais palestiniens et pavel et les
arabes d'israël
pourquoi ils n'ont pas bougé et pourquoi
il ne bouge toujours pas et bien tout
simplement parce qu'il n'approuve pas
les méthodes du tram as il n'approuve
pas qu'on mette en danger la coexistence
que nous avons toujours eu entre arabes
et juifs et c'est pour ça que donc vous
êtes dans l'erreur et vous maintenez
toujours ce que j'ai réussi je suis
toujours fait remarquer
ma vie interrompue je ne vous ai pas
interrompu alors puisqu'on interne sans
cesse écouter parler tout seul comme ça
la discussion du seul jacques bilot
ritter juste j'avais raison mais ce
qu'on voulait dire juste pour vous dire
que des affrontements meurtriers ont eu
lieu hier en cisjordanie justement
puisque d'ailleurs onze palestiniens ont
perdu la vie dont il y en a eu des
affrontements hier jeu depuis
si depuis je vais continuer je ne sais
pas j'étais indigné un petit pas très
vieux mais en même temps ça me plaît
j'allais à la peine nous n'arrivons nous
n'avons seront pas le problème vous les
diplomates c'est que vous parlez
toujours ceux du passé si nous voulons
régler le problème parlons du présent
essayons de régler le problème comme
nous avons essayé de le régler à
l'époque mail à chaque fois vous revenez
sur des problèmes juridiques sur le c'ur
de 1947 avant elle vous regarde alors
expliquez-moi fond de conditions
d'aujourd'hui pas d'hier et d'avant-hier
écoutez je crois que vous êtes mal
placés pour les peuples pour parler au
nom de ceux qui ne revendique jamais le
passé vous êtes très mal placé mais
enfin moi je ne parlais pas du passé en
l'occurrence je parle du présent est-ce
qu'il ya deux depuis huit ou quinze
jours
et effectivement c'est tout le peuple
palestinien est en situation difficile
en ce cas ce qui est requis réprimait
qui ne peut pas exprimer ses droits et
qui est très peu importe où il fait
partie où c'est le délire appelé les
arabes israéliens qui sont traités comme
des citoyens de deuxième zone
je crois que c'est l'organisation human
rights watch non pas ya 50 ans mais
maintenant d'y accusé israël de mener
une politique d'apartheid
ou bien les habitants des territoires
dits occupe elle qui représentent
d'ailleurs plus grand chose du point de
vue de la population palestinienne
puisque je crois que c'est quelque chose
comme 9 ou 10 % de la palestine
historique qui est sous contrôle ou
soupçonne aux contrôles eux palestinien
est formé ensuite israélien est-ce qu'on
peut pas bouger sur cent dont il avaient
demandé la permission à israël vous
dites que les diplomates parlent
toujours du droit international c'est
donc c'est normal parce que paru il
s'occupe du droit international
je vous fais remarquer je n'ai pas du
tout parlé de le du passé je pense qu'il
ya suffisamment de gens qui l'invoquent
comme ça pour justifier y compris leurs
excès demain
non pour ne pas parler du passé je parle
du présent pour le présent y'a pas il
faut pas si on veut régler le problème
et penser à l'avenir comme vous ne serez
pas parce que vous ne traitez pas le
problème tel qu'il existe je pense que
il faut remarquer qu' il ne faut pas y
ait deux poids deux mesures on parle à
la fois des arabes palestiniens et des
israéliens
deuxièmement je pense que il n'ya pas de
paix sans justice c'est un ya pas de
justice c'est-à-dire d'égalité des
droits est de rendre leurs droits tous
les habitants durera pas de paix et
ensuite pour qu'il y ait une paix
justice
il faut qu'on revienne au droit
international qui n'existe plus qui est
bafouée non pas par les palestiniens
med par le gouvernement israélien je ne
suis pas seul à l'intérieur toujours pas
désigné à dire mais vous verrez des gens
sans âme aux coûts de développement pour
l'instant de votre part deux par deux de
telle ou telle autre intervenant qui
explique que c'est que tout ça c'est pas
vrai que c'est du baratin
non c'est pas du baratin je ne parle
même pas de la manifestation de paris je
parle de la situation sur le terrain
daba girerd pas les mêmes derrière mais
je pense qu'on mérite de répondre ou
corriger une de vos erreurs
il n'y a pas 10 % d'arabes en
cisjordanie a mis en garde le principe
de non échange est pas ce que je veux ce
que j'ai dit j'ai arrivée m l'autorité
palestinienne sous contrôle palestinien
cette annexion en injection et de dison
de grignotage en grignotage des accords
passés où nous passés ou à venir
et bien que l'autorité palestinienne
contre les 10 % du territoire j'ai pas
big dipper vous avez intérêt à
renouveler votre documentation la non
présentation elle est très très bon
croyez-moi je si ce problème là depuis
très très longtemps j'ai dû très bonne
documentation désespérément un jour que
la vôtre sièges alors permettez-moi un
bic vous avez tort de dire que la
population arabe n'est pas ça elle une
zac jours
deux cent vingt pour cent des dents les
tuer
vous avez le de l'obligation d'accepter
dans certains cas des ouvriers arabes
aujourd'hui 30% de paix et médecins sont
arabes ou aujourd'hui 4 50 % des
infirmières son parrain et si nous avons
vaincu la pandémie aujourd'hui c'est
grâce aux arabes parce qu'ils ont
collaboré avec israël
ils se sont sentis nationaux avant
d'être arabe et ses deux essais étaient
vaccinés par anna deuxièmement quand
vous dites que y'a vous ne vous ne voyez
pas le problème tous les métiers leurs
se rouler aujourd'hui nous avons
uniquement d'arabes israéliens
ça on le savait pas il faut enseigner
je vous accuse pas de deux parties je
vous accuse de ne pas suivre les
informations
il faut remiser généraux c'est le rambo
comment est ce qu'on fait pour sortir de
cette crise comment est ce qu'on fait
pour à régler ce conflit qui est vieux
de plus de sept décennies est ce que la
communauté internationale doit taper du
poing sur la table aux pauvres en
quelque sorte convaincre israël de de
faire israël et l'autorité palestinienne
également de faire plus d'efforts ah ben
oui je pense à gré sont à
l'international mais pas une communauté
internationale entre guillemets qui est
composé des trois pays occidentaux
membres du conseil de sécurité m
permanent parce que ça c'est une fausse
communauté internationale et elle a une
vision qui est partisane des affaires
uniquement le disant le gouvernement
israélien et pour le reste si on a le
camp eh bien on a des préoccupations
pour la population civile palestinienne
qu'elle soit dans les territoires
occupés à gaza ou ou bien que ce soit y
compris les citoyens arabes israéliens
alors je ne mélange pas nous tous les
données j'ai ma documentation est
parfaitement à jour et je crois que
c'est dans ces conditions là ça
s'appelle le respect du droit vote 2
points
deux mesures on ne peut pas voir
seulement des préoccupations pour la
préoccupant aulas pour la population
civile palestinienne
après avoir justifié finalement il y
accusait et justifiait tout la
répression contre les palestiniens
on ne veulent pas jacques benillouche
oui alors ce que c'est je veux justement
pour sortir de cette crise est ce qu on
doit se servir des fondations du passé
pour créer un meilleur avenir
je pense qu'il faut il faut laisser
faire les choses entre israël et les
palestiniens
vous devez savoir si aujourd'hui le
ramage se révolte c'est parce que là le
le le procès lui le problème palestinien
a été ignorée par tous les pays arabes
vous savez qu'il ya quatre pays a que
viennent de normaliser les relations
avec israël
les émirats arabes unis le maroc et le
barrel et le roméo mal tout simplement
et ils ont décidé de laisser de côté le
problème palestinien et ils ont accepté
de renouveler les relations
pourquoi parce que le problème
palestinien n'avançait pas nous avons un
vieillard de 86 ans qui bloque la
situation pendant vingt ans vous qu'il
est un démocrate
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous accepter
qu'il n'y ait pas d'élections dans un
pays et qu'on ne permet pas à la
population de ce s'exprimer vous avez
trois listes aujourd'hui qui se présente
contre mahmoud abbas pourquoi ce sont
des gens intelligents qui ont compris
qu'il faut faire évoluer le droit à
l'eau on parlait toujours de droit mais
le droit il y en a pas puisque on a un
gouvernement qui n'est pas rée reconnu
qui n'est pas légal et donc comment
voulez vous qu israël négocié si on ne
négocie pas avec un gouvernement légal
alors d'abord que les palestiniens
fassent leur élection comme c'était
prévu éventuellement que le ramasse
gagne c'est son problème et c'est le
problème des palestiniens et à partir de
là nous négocierons moi je suis certain
nous arriverons à négocier et à trouver
une solution
s'il ne se
tête à tête si nous faisons intervenir
des gens extérieurs et bien nous
n'arriverons pas par exemple cette
manifestation en france est inadmissible
pourquoi le problème palestinien doit
être envoyé en france ça ne concerne pas
les français
c'est un problème palestinien non ces
manifestations sont saufs sont hors
sujet il faut c'est en faisant ce genre
de manifestation que nous n'arrivons pas
à nous entendre
dès l'instant nous sommes les israéliens
sont face aux arabes
ils trouveront une solution comme on l'a
trouvée avec les émirats arabes
comment la trouvez avec le maroc comme
on va le trouver bientôt avec l'arabie
saoudite
il faut que les gens se parlent ce sera
le monde d'accord avec jacques
benillouche une issue au vert il ya une
falsification et me sens des réalités
d'abord il ya d'abord pour promettre une
documentation à jour par exemple
d'abriel sous-tend quentin normalise
également que l'accord ait mis si je
pense que par contre ce qu'il faut car
il ya quelque chose qui s'impose
absolument
on peut pas dire que ça ne concerne pas
la france on voit pas bien ou pas ça
concerne tous les pays a des bonnes
prestations dans tous les pays où on pas
très bien pourquoi la france fait
exception
si elle fait exception c'est parce
qu'elle peut-être fm davantage deux
poids deux mesures que d'autres pays
européens aux pays occidentaux
c'est le comme ça qu'elle se distingue
et c'est bien dommage de la balle cette
exception française
par contre je suggérerais loi israël
quand même un truc pour faciliter le
règlement de la situation
c'est peut-être de reprend dans les
innombrables résolutions du conseil de
sécurité et l'assemblée générale des
nations unies depuis excusez moi
monsieur et je vais être un diplomate ya
un historien en plus depuis la création
de l'état d'israël toutes ces
résolutions wade passe ou ignorés violé
régulièrement systématiquement comme si
elles n'existaient pas à pour un état
qui a été créée par les nations unies
par une résolution des nations unies
je crois que si ces résolutions là
étaient toutes appliquées ou seulement
quelques unes vous les plus importantes
d'entre elles je crois qu'on aurait déjà
fait un énorme propre un énorme progrès
seulement je ne sois pas que ça soit
dans les techniques du
demande israël vient d'engager cette
solution leasing qui soutiennent le
gouvernement israélien je suis d'accord
avec juste les mots je suis d'accord
avec nous
je suis d'abord et une minute je suis
d'accord avec vous à condition que les
arabes aussi respecte les résolutions et
la résolution de 1947 qui crée deux
états à ce jour les pays arabes ne l'ont
pas accepté c'est le début des problèmes
si les paysagistes
nous acceptons la résolution de 1945 qui
crée deux états arabes et juifs côte à
côte
eh bien on aura déjà trouvé 80 % de la
solution aux perdants ans hormis sera
elle sait qu il a ajouté que cette
rentes fière aussi de la solution qui
est de respecter le statut de jérusalem
et de ne pas voir annexe et disons et
effet 10 à occuper totalement la ville
de jérusalem qui devait avoir un statut
international de ville sainte
ça ça n'a jamais été respecté ni
peut-être je ne sais pas par les arabes
mais paris et l'israël qui détenait dans
un bled mais voilà c'est john les médias
ne touche à sa fin merci riche est
michele rango je rappelle que vous êtes
essayiste et ancien ambassadeur de
france merci à vous également jacques
benillouche vous jette vous êtes
journaliste indépendant basé à tel aviv
merci merci à tous les deux